so we've now gotten a look at a new
costume for the 14th no 15th doctor I
keep losing track of it tennis the 14th
15th doctor shittigatwa because we got
this image now what I like about this is
it is a different look it's different
material it's a different jacket but
it's all in the same color scheme with
what we had already seen before and if
that's the kind of variance we're gonna
do I actually rather like that as much
as I enjoyed some of Capaldi's outfits I
didn't really like that the main variant
seemed to be just changing the shirt
that he had underneath the uh coat a lot
of the time and then with Matt Smith
they actually like did a big shift in
color but always we're sure to keep the
bow tie in the jacket and with tenant it
was you know the blue and the Pinstripe
but they're both suits I like this idea
that the outfit is actually kind of
different in any aspect other than the
color scheme I like that as the through
line